hey guys welcome back to brain uvt we're
back on fawning and today's gonna be a
pretty short video the stream was about
maybe 20 minutes along in terms of good
info so I'm gonna rifle through all this
so that you guys can get on with your
day my Twitter and discord will be in
the description if you guys want to hang
out on there with that let's get started
so first up there is a weekly sale and
all the ornaments in the game are gonna
be discounted that's what the dev said
they're gonna be coming from 5k steel
which is the original price down to 3000
steel so if there's any really cool
ornaments that you want to get that
aren't tournament of course then you can
buy those for 3,000 steel on top of that
today is March 28th so that means the
Blackfriars were pasta event is over but
don't worry if you didn't end up
grabbing the gear no problem because
there is a bundle for every single
character and that's gonna be going till
April 1st the starting price is thirty
thousand steel but the more items that
you got throughout the event that
cheaper the price is as to not have you
pay double for the same thing to check
the bundle tab if you want to get the
last bit of stuff for your character
before the event runs out they're also
going to be getting rid of weekly
content and this is kind of for a
slightly good reason the main goal is to
lessen the amount of battle outfits that
we get every week as to focus on more
and providing us with better content
like executions ornaments mythix and
effects a lot more often now I don't
know if that means that these effects
these executions are going to be coming
more in bundles and there's gonna be a
lot more because as you guys know in
terms of with executions but we only get
like one group per season I'm assuming
that we're gonna be getting a lot more
per season or either the quality is
gonna be a lot better I mean at least to
me I believe the executions have really
good quality in general they do a very
good job on those but I'm hoping that
that means we're gonna be getting a lot
more executions per season which is
always nice to see because everybody
loves those and then also in the next
coming weeks there's gonna be something
about tournaments happening and I'm not
really sure what that means I don't know
if for honor is finally gonna be
bringing back the duel tournament or if
there's going to be another tournament
like we had I believe in season two or
season 3 where the grand prize was ten
thousand dollars I don't know whatever
one of those means but I hope it's gonna
be the big tournament happening for the
$10,000 pool like we had a couple
seasons ago because that is the case I
will definitely try to participate in
that definitely not gonna win it but I
think would be cool to stream anyway so
let me know if that happens if you guys
want to see that stream yeah like I said
nothing crazy of a video pretty dang
sadly hopefully we'll mate we may be
getting some info in the next couple
weeks maybe what this tournament mode is
hopefully we get something throughout
the weeks and it's not just a boring
couple weeks until they see until the
season is over and then we start getting
into season ten but that is gonna be the
question for season 10 I do believe that
the season 10 hero is actually a samurai
definitely correct me in the comments if
I'm wrong but if the season 10 hero is a
samurai what do you guys think he'll be
in terms of his weapon he does have a
double-headed ax let me know your
thoughts on what that character is gonna
look like what you think he's gonna do
what some of his moves might be just any
type of brainstorming activity anything
you guys think that will come with this
character in season I'd love to know all
her thoughts about him and with that
like the VP do enjoy subscriber for new
I cover the informational slide a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes of the
leaks so if you definitely want to see
more of that if we stay subscribe to the
channel my two most recent videos are
gonna be popping up if you guys want to
check those out we got some nice simple
to talk about in those videos and with
that have a great yesterday peace out
and enjoy the rest your day
[Music]